das congstar komplett willkommen bayern
ein video
ja ich bin ja selbst aber ich habe schon
mein führerschein klasse
und da ich halte mein führerschein mit
17 gemacht habe ich mir so gedacht hey
macht einfach mal ein video dazu erzählt
seinen zuschauern wieder weg dahin so
war theoretische prüfungen praktische
prüfung wie das ganze so verlaufen ist
und auf geht's heute und ihr seht mich
gleich wahrscheinlich auch autofahren
also was heißt wahrscheinlich ich mache
das gleich ja und eigentlich geht das ja
alles so los indem man sich erst mal bei
einer fahrschule anmeldet und ich muss
euch auch ganz ehrlich sagen so ich
hatte auch überhaupt keinen plan wie das
jetzt überhaupt so alles abläuft ich
meinen mann stellt sich das ja
eigentlich so übel ist langweilig vor
aber man sollte solche theoriestunden
wirklich auf keinen fall mit schule
vergleichen weil ich meine wir sind
wirklich zum teil lustig auch
interessant und es gibt eigentlich nur
witzige und nette fahrlehrer also war
bei mir zumindest der fall da gibt's ja
erst mal 14 theoriestunden die man so
absolvieren muss und dann kann man halt
theoretisch die theorieprüfung machen
man hört ja immer so theorieprüfung
führerschein oder praktische prüfung das
schaffe ich nie das ist alles so schwer
macht euch dann wirklich keinen kopf
also wenn ihr wirklich frühzeitig
anfangen dafür zu üben weil jetzt nicht
eine woche vorher sondern wirklich
frühzeitig dann ist das wirklich für
jeden machbar
das ganze ist natürlich ein bisschen mit
lärm verbunden und deswegen rate ich
euch auch hier an dieser stelle setzt
euch wirklich oder was heißt setzt euch
hin schiebt das ganze mit dem
führerschein jetzt nicht so weit aus
dass ihr den wirklich erst mit 1819
macht wenn ihr pech habe seid ihr dann
gerade genau in den abiprüfungen es gibt
ja auch noch so viel was man an zu
erledigen hat sein ist jetzt
bewerbungsschreiben auch irgendwie ums
studium sich kümmern und so weiter
deswegen kann ich nur aus meinen
erfahrungen jetzt sagen zieht das
einfach durch frühzeitig und dann
vermeidet stress wenn ihr da die
theoretische prüfung gemeistert habt
dann geht das ja auch weiter mit
fahrstunden und irgendwann kommen dann
halt die praktische prüfung das ist auch
eine sache dann wirklich ganz viele
leute angst vor ich selber hatte
natürlich auch ein bisschen angst dass
auch wirklich noch mal vor der
praktischen prüfung aufgeregt zu sein
aber macht euch doch wirklich nicht
verrückt wenn ich meine jeder im auto
wirklich jeder an selbst der prüfer
möchte dass ihr den führerschein auf
jeden fall besteht deswegen das auch
wirklich auf eurer seite und
unterstützte ein bisschen also bei mir
persönlich war es wirklich ganz locker
ich meine ich bin ins auto gestiegen der
prüfer hat mir dann gesagt ja erklären
wir doch mal was das und das ist dann
abheben kurz was erklärt am auto dann
muss ich los fahren bin dann irgendwie
so eine dreiviertel stunde gefahren war
da am tisch das ganze startet und er war
wirklich super nett ging alles ganz
locker am ende deutlich helfer hopp mehr
zu einem kopfsprung gemacht also hab' da
wirklich keine angst
ach ja und was ich dazu noch sagen kann
wenn ihr aus irgendeinem grund eventuell
durchfall dann noch nicht da wirklich
keinen kopf darum macht einfach nochmal
kann jedem passieren und ist auch
wirklich nicht schlimm
klar ist was du dann ein bisschen mehr
geld aber gut ist dann halt so bevor ich
wieder ins auto setze mich dann halt
dabei beobachten können wollte noch mal
schnell auf der seite aufmerksam machen
und zwar ist das bf 17 punkte ist in der
video beschreibung verlinkt dort findet
ihr informationen tipps alles rund ums
thema führerschein mit 17 hat jack dass
auf jeden fall ab ja dann würde ich
sagen ich bin jetzt mal ins auto ich bin
ja noch 17 das heißt meine mutter oder
mein vater die muss ich jetzt mal lieb
fragen auf die mitkommen weil sonst
geht's leider nicht ob das wird schon
alle angeschnallt
was aus
nein
davor war 70 alles klappt jetzt ist ihr
super
gott sei dank so jetzt bin ich wieder
hier in meinem zimmer und zwar ist mir
so eingefallen ich könnte euch
eigentlich noch was dazu erzählt wieso
meine erste fahrt mit dem fahrschulauto
war und was ich da gemacht habe ob alles
gut verlief auf dem unfall passiert ist
oder nicht und nein es ist kein unfall
passiert das war nicht alles ich habe
mir autofahren eigentlich mega schwer
vorgestellt aber es ist eigentlich total
einfach ich meine gut ich glaub das ist
bei jeder fahrschule normal am anfang
der fahrschüler oder fahrschülerin erste
praktische stunde da denkt man
eigentlich nur vielleicht schaltet man
schon mal aber die kupplung kommen
lassen
bremsen und so weiter das kommt halt
erst mit der zeit dazu aber bei mir ist
alles super verlaufen ich glaube ich
hab's ganz gut auf die reihe bekommen
und ich kann euch wirklich sagen freut
euch einfach auf eure erste falschen
weil es macht einfach richtig spaß auto
zu fahren und habe da keine angst oder
sonst irgendwas ja als ich dann meinen
führerschein hat und das erste mal mit
unserem auto gefahren bin das war
natürlich noch mal eine umstellung ja
wer denn was ich mir als weiteren punkt
auch so überlegt habe ich bin ja jetzt
18 wald am heute glaube ich sogar wenn
das video kommt eltern bin ich 18 auf
jeden fall kommen nächste woche montag
am 21
ein video wo ich halt wirklich das erste
mal alleine vater selbst ein kumpel
meter nimmt das auf und ich und ich
nehme einfach mal so ein bisschen mit
mal gucken ob alles gut geht aber
bestimmt und ich freue mich schon halt
mega summe rein zu fahren und ja das
sind auf jeden fall ab würde ich sagen
also wir sehen uns nächsten montag
kathrein danke fürs zuschauen bis job